- What we're going to do in this video
is get some practice writing
reasonably large numbers
in different ways.
So, for example, let's
say we had this number
and I'm going to not say
it out loud on purpose.
So, this number right over here.
What I wanna do is think
about how would I write this out in words?
And I encourage you to pause this video
and try to figure that out on your own
before we do it together.
And if you take out paper
and actually write this out,
how would you write this number?
Well now, we can do it together.
Actually before I even
write it out in words,
I'll write this out in a place value table
'cause it might help
us, or it just helps us
break down exactly what
this number represents.
So, just as a bit of a refresher,
if you're not familiar
with place value tables.
You think of a column for
the different place values
and here we're going from the ones place
all the way to 10s, 1,000s, 10,000s,
so we're going to have a 10,0000s
place right over here.
We're going to have a 1,000s
This is just an S here, so
ten thousands, one thousands.
Sometimes you'll see it written out.
This is the 100s place.
This is the 10s place.
And this is the ones place.
And so, how many 10,000s do we have?
Actually, let's start at the ones place.
How many ones do we have?
We see it right here.
We have five ones.
How many 10s do we have?
We see it right there,
actually, we have zero 10s.
How many 100s do we have?
We see it right there, six 100s.
How many 1,000s?
We go to the 1,000s place
and we see we have two 1,000s.
And then, how many 10,000s we have?
Well, we see right there,
we have eight 10,000s.
So now that we have this representation,
let's write it out in words
and you don't have to do this every time,
but I am just trying to make sure we see
every possible way of thinking about it.
So, you could say eight 10s,
two 1,000s, six 100s, and five ones,
but that's not exactly how
people would say it out in words.
What is typical is that people would say
82 1,000s, 600 and five.
And so I'm gonna write it that way.
And when you write it out in words,
the standard way of doing
it is actually put commas
wherever you put the commas in,
this is right over here
written in standard form.
So what we would do is,
we would express this part
right over here as eighty-two thousand,
so let me write it out.
Eighty two thousand.
And then, put this comma there.
Eighty two thousand, comma,
and then we have 600
and then we have no 10s,
so it's 605.
If there was a one 10 here,
then it would have been 615,
but this is just 605.
And so I will do it in a different color.
Let's do it in this blue color.
So eighty-two thousand,
and then six hundred five.
And we're done!
Let's do another example.
So now I'm gonna write
out a number in words
and I want you to write
it in standard form.
So, the number is fifty
thousand, six hundred thirty-one.
And I want you to write
this in standard form.
So it's really just
write it out as a number
and put commas in the appropriate places.
Pause this video and
see if you can do that.
All right, now let's do it together.
So, this first part, fifty thousand,
well, we could just write that as,
actually, let's put the
place values out here,
so there's a 10,000s place,
this is a 1,000s place,
100s, 10s, and ones.
So, fifty thousand, so 50 1,000s,
you could write like this,
you could say that's five 10,000s,
or you could say this is 50 1,000s.
Then they say six hundred thirty-one.
So, six hundred, well that's
six 100s right over here
and then thirty-one,
that is thirty and one,
or three 10s and one one,
three 10s and one one, or 31.
And of course, you wanna put your comma
in the same place, and you put your comma
every three places, so
the first time you do it,
if you're moving from the right,
you put it between the
100s and the 1,000s place.
So, there you have it.
This is the same thing as 50,631.
This is that number written in stand form.